our tour first of all uh welcome to St
Louis welcome to the Juniors uh this was
an incredible start to the tournament
for you probably the biggest upset up to
this point tell us a bit about your
emotions right now yeah I mean coming
into this tournament um I don't expect
much being the lowest seed
um and every game I kind of just told
myself I want to put up a fight I want
to make myself
um not lose easily
um and coming to this first round
without much expectations being able to
kind of get a win
um I mean it feels great yeah is that
something that you put a price on just
not coming into this event with pressure
on your shoulders yeah I mean that's
very important to me because I just want
to take all that pressure off kind of
enjoy the tournament enjoy playing
against all these top players
um and I think that helps for sure well
you definitely put a lot of pressure on
your opponents and especially in this
game take us through the game and
um where did your opening preparation
ends um because it felt like you were
very it was rather long um I think it
ended near something like move 18. oh
wow
um so actually this is our preparation
this is a typical line but at the same
time and at this point he had one hour
and 30 he knew as well right but this
move E4 perhaps was a little bit off the
bidding tracks
now B4 is this where he felt like you're
finally taking over like getting an
advantage
um I remember in my preparation that
you're supposed to play Rook d8 first
before yes um and I would play Queen E2
and then he would play E4 Bishop C2 and
I think this is around equal I think
um but by playing E4 first I can play
Queen H5 and I thought that was a better
version for me because my queen is I
mean much better situated
on that square that's right that's
exactly what it is yeah yeah
um
and kind of yeah I wasn't really sure
why he allowed me to take on d8 and
I thought it Rook takes he would play
rotate C1 Bishop takes D1 and then
someone F5 and play I think G3
um I thought a pretty normal position
but he allowed me to take on d8 and kind
of expose his King so I thought I mean
that was kind of good for me
and right now he was still playing quite
quickly but missing a lot of details and
you spotted this beautiful Bishop to B3
yeah did you understand that at this
point you're probably completely winning
um I say I knew it should be three is a
correct move and then I started
calculating and then I realized that oh
wait a minute he doesn't have any moves
now and that's kind of when I realized
Queen to F6 what was your uh I believe
Knight G4 Knight G4 yeah and then
Queen is overloaded yeah yeah yeah you
cannot defend D5 or and E7 at the same
time very nice game and I have to say we
missed the final move but it was so
beautiful right Queen takes 25 Queen
takes C8 a stylish way to finish this
game congratulations uh Arthur and
welcome to St Louis thank you absolutely
our congratulations to Arthur very very
nice uh Victory indeed and like you say
you're the lowest rated seed so no
pressure on you you take you take your
wins when they come right they're very
nice good luck in the rest of the
tournament arthro congratulations on
your when I have a question so you
qualified here by winning the 2022 us
Juniors open how was that did you
prepare for that tournament to win the
event and qualify here or did it happen
out of nowhere and how did you feel
about it
um um
it honestly kind of happened out of
nowhere
um I played that tournament I mean I
played that tournament basically every
year
um and what happened was I think
um I was actually tied for first with
the top scene that tournament um
tugstomer and he was he's tybreak was
hiring so he was supposed to play here
but his Federation was Mongolia so he
was not allowed and so I somehow managed
to qualify for this tournament so it was
completely unexpected but I thought I
mean it was a great opportunity I
thought I would have a lot of fun here
um great opportunity again so I decided
to play here
okay awesome congratulations and good
luck in the rest of the tournament thank
you